good
morning millennials happy wednesday
welcome back to the morning toast it is
that's why theo's here to get us all in
the hump day move oh we'd love to see it
today's such an amazing hump day because
it really feels like a monday coming
into studio for the first time this week
and
this week has just been so unexpected so
beautiful so special
but i am really happy to be back but the
two snow days i have to say like
were there i didn't even realize like
was the reset i needed so badly even
after a weekend
so so badly like i need to treat my
weekends because we got two days in a
weekend and we had two snow days and
like
what i did in those two snow days like i
need to treat my weekends like that yeah
it's like a work day but i'm relaxing i
don't know why i have like so much value
for like days off that i get
on during the week and i have no respect
for like the actual weekends that i get
every week i just like treat myself like
[ __ ] i sleep like [ __ ]
i don't actually reset and what would
the world be if i was like
so intentional with my time on the
weekends you know showered
both days and and red and you know eight
nourishing healthy food like yeah i
think i gotta start doing that yeah i
think it's time to be intentional
yeah it's like waking up every [ __ ]
um week
weekend morning and like feeling
hungover vomiting and eating mcdonald's
like that's just not a way to nourish
your body
no i have to learned a lot about my body
in the last two days
and i'm very excited to be back in
studio we we really really miss
being here but the monday and tuesday's
episodes were like so fun just there was
just
it was like the snow was just like a
blanket over the city and i was
cuddled up in it yeah and now the
blanket has turned to like duty brown
slush you love because i just feel like
it's not said enough as in snowden new
york if claudia's not talking about the
duty
because people romanticize winter in new
york and they like glorify the snow
and like yes okay sitting on the
hundredth floor of a building looking at
the snow it's nice
walking to work real life having a dog
like you are not a new yorker unless you
eat
[ __ ] and like trying to cross the street
and like other people that come and help
you up and it's so embarrassing
that's so bad do you remember like the
first time you fell i do
yeah but i don't think it was in new
york like
so snowy they're so icy and hilly kill
me oh so embarrassing yeah that's so
embarrassing so like compared to that
the streets of new york are breeze plus
when you got your moon boots on like
literally i walked so slowly but
very carefully but there was like no
snow plow no snow
i mean no salt i'll never forget the
first time i fell in the snow i was down
at nyu
and i was walking to my internship and i
was like feeling myself you know like i
got dressed
special for the internship yeah nothing
says like brave courageous like wearing
heels in the snow
they were healed booties but yes it was
a two block walk from my dorm to 770
broadway like it was really short
and i'm crossing broadway and
they do this thing where like they pile
all the snow into the corners
of the street so like there's no way to
cross the street the street is empty but
the corner and so i just like lost my
balance and i remember before i fell i
did like the oh
like my feet were sliding and like the
guy next to me looked at me like he knew
i was going down we made eye contact and
i'm like sir
it's over for me like please save
yourself
and it was so mortifyingly embarrassing
and the pain
not to mention not the physical pain
yeah no not most emotional i think the
emotional pain is worse
guaranteed and that's what has stood
with like stayed with you to this day
of course i'm not even thinking about
like my sore thigh i'm thinking about
the shame
i've harbored absolute shame but it is a
rite of passage
yeah in any snowy city or in life i
think falling like literally falling on
your ass
is something that everyone has to go
through yeah and you know what like
brings me
peace at night is that like even famous
people fall you know like no matter who
you are jeff bezos like slips and
he twists his ankle when he's just like
going for a jog you know everyone does
it
and that makes me feel so so good jeff
bezos stops his toe
yeah and then he gets like so badly like
cursey's like oh [ __ ] you know like
he also has like sweaty diarrhea too
like i just love thinking of
really famous wealthy people in
compromising human positions
yeah sweaty diarrhea being one of them
shawn mendes
love to see it he has diarrhea i bet you
don't know that
now fun fact about shawn mendes he
suffers from the occasional
diarrhea oh wow
well we have so much to discuss today we
have so many stories that we need to get
into
it's also wednesday so we got to your
toasters of dallas recap
yes i watched the past two episodes of
real house of housewives of dallas which
was
a treat i finished the redheads book
last night which was so good and really
such a
great compliment to the other book the
wonderful book that we read this month
we're recording the episode of the
redheads tonight i'm actually really
really i'm always really excited
for the redheads yeah it's like two and
two weeks it's a lot for us oh wow it
feels like i'm
like being left out you don't wanna come
well i was gonna read the book but you
were we should we share a kindle account
and by share i mean i just like stole
yours and i bought two books yesterday
sorry i'll venmo you
um what was the second book so i had i
gave up on the last mrs paris
even though so many people were like
part two is so good i just like it's
moving so
it's just so bad i recently learned that
you are not supposed to finish books you
don't like like if you
get into a book and you realize you
don't like it do not keep reading that's
what i learned i would have thought the
opposite
but no so then i started night road
which counselor recommended to me
i've never heard of it um and then i
like by the time i bought that one i was
just like
fatigued with looking so i just watched
tv understood it's like when you watch
so many trailers on netflix yeah and
then you don't watch anything but now i
have
a book and a half maybe i'll finish mrs
parish like if i'm bored on the beach
once
like now i have two books in the future
that i will at some point in my life
complete very exciting yeah love to see
you reading not on vacation what do you
think about the act
and i want to watch i don't want to read
how to fail at flirting that's what i
was going to say
but you were reading it and i didn't
want to [ __ ] up your page no you already
said that
oh i did yeah wow amnesia is on today
what do you think about reading from
home rfh
you know it's good because i've through
quarantine quarantine i think maybe
people can relate to this like
at first it was like yes let's stay up
all night and watch television
and now it's like if i turn my tv on
i'll throw up like i'm just like so
done with my television because it's
just i've officially reached
the point where i have watched too much
tv and so i just sit and like scroll
tick-tock and then i get up and get a
snack and i go back to tick-tock it's
just like
kind of boring and these last few months
i haven't figured out like where to put
my attention and my time
and reading at home not on a beach which
is what i'm used to
is quite lovely so happy that
so happy to hear it yeah but i also
think i should go to a beach soon just
to test the theory and make sure it's
better to read on it
oh yeah for sure for research for that
reason only yeah
well should we get into what we came
here to do today yeah i mean
i have a heavy heart with one of our
stories today and
i think we should talk about it so let's
do it yeah so let's get right into the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and that's true that is did you lie
no i didn't i don't you don't lie i try
not to but you might have misspoke
oh because and that
misspokenness really got me feeling kind
of sick you know like kind of like
like rda stick your stomach to my
stomach um today's episode is brought to
you by hum nutrition
formulated by experts and rigorously
tested each unique hum nutrition
supplement
packs a combo of potent clean and
clinically proven ingredients designed
for specific goals
like clear skin improved skin hair
growth balanced mood
and healthier body to help boost your
well-being in the ways you need it most
take their quick quiz and get
individualized product recommendations
from their team of registered dietitians
to help bring your skin
body hormones and mood into balance with
hum nutrition
we love a quick quiz here at the morning
toast because honestly all bodies are
not created equally and not everyone
needs the same vitamins like
i suffer from headaches i get fatigue at
like three four o'clock
i have a lot of i have very poor memory
like those would be my
those are the things that i need
tailored when it comes to vitamins i
don't need the same things as you
and that's why we take the quiz and we
love that we love a quiz um so they also
i think some of their most popular
products that i have actually
started to take are the hair sweet hair
uh vegan gummy
it boosts your body's ability to
maintain healthy vibrant hair and
support hair growth
which i think a lot of people um can
relate to
they also have calm sweet calm which is
a vegan sour cherry gummy formulated to
have
formulated with a potent blend of
ashwagandha and
l-theanine two all-star ingredients
proven to help reduce stress symptoms
and lower levels of the stress hormone
cortisol
so they have fabulous products literally
for every need in your life and
if you want to take the quiz they'll
tell you what you need and if you want
to get 15 off your first order
use the code toast plus they have a
flexible subscription option
and chic packaging it's insanely easy to
stay on top of your daily dosage
too again so that's hum nutrition dot
com use the code toast for 15
off and yeah it's it's the best thing
out there
their effective unique formulas are
personalized to your needs and proven by
clinical research
one small change done daily can help
transform everything that's true like
for hub nutrition and for life a hundred
percent
okay first story is the big news of the
day morgan wallin hurls the n
word after a rowdy night out he
apologizes saying quote i promise to do
better
so tmz has the exclusive morgan wallin
returned home
sunday from a rowdy night with friends
and as he walked up to his driveway
he hurled the n-word and other
profanities and it's all on video and
wallen is remorseful
the country star and a group of buddies
had just spent a night out in nashville
when they arrived at morgan's home
at around midnight they were extremely
loud honking horns and talking loudly
loud enough to piss off the neighbors
one of the neighbors began recording the
antics on what appears to be a ring
like that's what it looks like oh that's
interesting i didn't know that the
neighbor was the one who took the
video yes so morgan mullen then
sent out a statement it seems like to
all of the major news outlets saying
quote i'm embarrassed and sorry
i used an unacceptable and inappropriate
racial slur that i wish i could take
back
there are no excuses to use this type of
language ever i want to sincerely
apologize
for using the word i promise to do
better i mean this is so
bad like i don't know this is so
disappointing this is so
so so disappointing so unacceptable and
i
have been such a big morgan wallin fan
and i think today is a very
upsetting day for those fans because
there is
this is just so unacceptable like it's
january 2021 how are you using that word
in conversation right and so casually
like
of course he didn't know he was being
filmed but so you see like his demeanor
he's with his friends
this is clearly a word that is in his
vocabulary and that is just not okay
whatsoever and i feel like one this
apology scene
that he put out is [ __ ] not gonna
cut it he did more of an apology when he
got you know in trouble for kissing a
girl in a bar because he had like a wife
at home like
i don't care what you do in a bar like i
want an apology here yeah
and i think he's gonna have to do much
more to
apologize for this but i also feel like
on a personal level like
he needs to look in the mirror and go on
a personal journey i think he needs
help i think there's been a lot of
stories about him recently like he's
drinking and his partying which is
absolutely no excuse but that's
definitely something he needs to get
under control if like he gets drunk and
this happens
yeah no i agree and then also just like
learning why what he's done is so wrong
so bad i agree he definitely
needs some sort of break and some help
to do some self-reflection i'm so
mad at him like when i when like i
defended him last time with his like
dumb like
you know kissing girls in bars like i
found a way around it like yeah
because i just do things i don't think
are compromised no
not at all and so when i saw this
headline i was so disappointed i was so
mad at him like
it's just i don't know first of all how
you even say that word like in this day
and age
or at all any time of year but it's just
this is like i'm so angry at him and i'm
sorry to anyone like i watched a video
and i'm sorry to anyone watch a video
and like
no one should have to hear that word you
know yeah i agree
i'm so angry at him so so angry
and a lot of people a lot of country
music artists are like talking about it
on social media and there's like two
conversations
going on it's like you know this is not
what country music represents
and then some people are like no no this
like is what it represents like this
is like a real problem in country music
like we should talk about it not like
brush it under the rug like
oh this is not what we're about you know
yeah cause like it's
of all the industries i'm sure they deal
with especially like some
the there aren't many black country
artists and i'm sure they deal with like
the worst of the worst so it's an
interesting conversation whether it's
like
something like should country music talk
about it more or like
you know it it's not whoever is just
like not reflective of country music but
i don't think it's reflective of country
music but i think country music has a
race problem
yeah i think that this in like enforce
reinforces like
a really negative stereotype about
country music and it makes
it makes the rest of the industry look
bad too a hundred percent
and i feel like yes that's something
that they need to figure out but also
like morgan while
this is on you you need to figure it out
like you're not going to hide behind the
industry and yeah the industry is like
what allowed you to become this person
yeah it's just
i'm so mad at him like so angry so
disappointed like
i had like and since i heard i've been
listening to the album like pretty much
the truckers for
morgan wallin are [ __ ] angry that's
an angry hunk that's not a trucker like
that they would do for taisha like no of
course not um i've been listening to the
album but like literally on repeat since
the last like two weeks i haven't been
able to listen to it since i'm
like i'm so mad at it now i feel the
same way if anyone wants to like put out
a fire album like now would be the time
somebody kind
and genuine and lovely yeah because i
have
an album hold in my yeah yeah i'm so
angry
yeah okay well are you ready for some
good news sure
out of the country music world okay oh
yes yes this is such great news tj
osborne who is one half of brothers
osborne
is ready to tell his story to time
magazine in an interview
with time he is coming out he says
that he's ready to put this behind him
that he has known that he's been gay for
a very long time and that
people close to him know but that's just
not something that he's uh felt
comfortable felt comfortable coming out
with
publicly and now he is he says quote i'm
very comfortable being gay
i find myself being guarded for not
wanting to talk about something that i
personally don't
have a problem with that feels so
strange right no i mean when i read this
i was
so shocked and i was so overcome with
joy i'm
such a big brothers osborne fan their
music is
sickening the barn down like it's so
[ __ ] good
and i don't know this is such a big deal
like i can't think off the top of my
head of any like huge country artists
male who are gay yeah and i just feel
like
it's like such a brave thing to do and
he's setting such a like an amazing
example and he's a pioneer and like
i'm so thrilled i'm so thrilled and we
always say like it's
he's obviously been his true self for a
very long time but to be someone in
private and in public that are as
different i think
can be tough difficult yeah yeah and so
when someone like
feels comfortable publicly being exactly
who they are and being proud to be that
person like i think that's the best
feeling in the world and that's what
i hope for for everyone yeah and i think
that like this
might encourage i don't know of anyone
specifically i'm saying i think this
might encourage
more people in the country music
industry to come out if they are gay
like it just
fosters a more welcoming environment
when you're not the first one
yeah i agree and i'm sorry i'm sure
there are
out male country artists that i'm not
remembering but to me in recent memory
this is like
the first one i'm sure there have been
so i don't want to like discredit but
for right now contemporary yes this is a
very big deal
yeah i i read it i was shocked like i
didn't i never thought of him
as anything other than straight because
his music is very like
you know yeah and when i saw it i was so
shocked and so excited like i'm
so happy for this is just a great great
story it's a great day to put on a
brother's ass born album oh yes
that's what we will do today that's what
we don't do the song tequila again
like is perhaps their album they put out
an album recently and it's really good
and i haven't gone through it enough so
that's what i'm going to put on
while i cook today literally that song
tequila again like
my favorite thing is to people who don't
like country music or have never heard
that song and make them listen to it
because there's like a trick in the
lyrics like
the whole first verse he's talking about
a girl and then in the chorus
i don't want to spoil it for anyone you
realize like the girl he's been talking
about is tequila
so i'm like did you see what he did
there
that's my favorite thing to do listen to
the song yeah no that's like a lot of
country music songs are like that where
it's like
yes yeah and it's like beer can
also like beard own that's a morgan
wallen song that yeah
that we're just we're not listening to
anymore not not right now
um okay ready for our next story yes
golden globe nominations are out
yes like who cares but literally
who [ __ ] cares i know but like one
the golden globes like as far as award
shows
are considered a big deal i was
interested to know like
what were the big shows of the year and
three as much as like celebrities have
become
so irrelevant and out of touch in the
last year tv kind of got us through
yeah but golden globes is movies and tv
yes sorry
i'm sorry like the arts kind of got us
through yeah no they did
so i was like what were the big shows
because there were so many shows all we
were doing this year was watching tv
yeah no i could definitely
tell you what the big shows are i'm
curious like what are the big movies
this year
are there anything so here are the here
are the nominees and we'll go through
each category tell me who you would vote
okay
as a member of the globe okay that was
golden of course the hollywood farm
press
yes no is that oscars whatever okay
best tv series musical or comedy the
flight
the flight attendant the great shit's
creek ted lasso
emily in paris are you kidding me i'm
not kidding like that's what makes
this that's how this was how you know it
was a bad year yeah and it's like
but it wasn't a bad year for tv no it
wasn't that is just so disgraceful for
this one it's either shit's creek or
maybe the flight attendant shit's creek
yeah shit's creek and plus
shit's creek swept the emmys it's the
year of shitscreen oh yeah best motion
picture musical or comedy
hairspray palm springs oh i heard that
was good
i watched it on the plane and it was
okay it's a groundhog day right
yes yes it was actually it was okay but
the fact that it's nominated is like
crazy okay it's been a tough year i
guess but like we were all watching
movies but movies
i feel like were more detected than tv
100 borat
music the prom hamilton
hamilton the hamilton that was like a
video disney plus vcr
like like a camcorder like um chris
jenner like someone like someone's mom
on their ipad
like um okay honestly i have not seen
any movie in that category yeah so i
can't give my professional opinion
no um i the only movie that i saw was
palm springs but like
i i can't believe that's nominated for
golden globe me too and in my mind
the only movie like i heard about
endlessly was hamilton like people were
dying over it so i want to say hamilton
yeah but then i also heard it was like
weird and you could hear them breathing
really because it was live action like
on the stage
okay this is really crazy best actor oh
no sorry best actor in the television
series drama
jason bateman for ozark josh o'connor
the crown
bob who's josh o'connor i think he's
prince um
okay excellent excellent
bob odenkirk better call saul al pacino
hunters
matthew reese perry mason oh al pacino
in hunters even though
they disgraced his character in like the
last
episode he was excellent i just feel
like i can't put my finger on who should
be nominated but it's not these people i
mean hunters i literally watched before
quarantine
like how was that this year yeah okay
this is what's crazy sorry best
supporting actress in a motion picture i
have not heard of
one of these oh pictures jodie foster
the mora
the mauritanian olivia coleman the
father glenn close hillbilly elegy
amanda seyfried menk helena zangel news
of the world
never heard of any of those movies never
heard of any of those movies so i'm just
gonna
keep going this next category is good
best actress in a mini series or
television film
kate blanchett mrs america daisy edgar
jones normal people
winner shira haas unorthodox so good
nicole kidman the undoing oh she's gonna
win but the winner i think anya taylor
joy queen's gambit
oh this is a very competitive category
this category this is the quarantine
category yes
i watched all of this in quarantine even
unorthodox that was like back when we
were doing
toast series yes and that was so good so
good i think any of them these could win
and i would be very very pleased i
totally agree
best actor in a mini series or
television film hugh grant the undoing
no i mean he wasn't that great but i
think that he was really good because
like
he had no idea what he was going like
how crazy he was
that's true that's true ethan hawk the
good lord bird
mark ruffalo i know this much is true i
kind of like
hot take ready i found mark buffalo to
be like one of the most annoying
celebrities like i feel like
whenever there's a celebrity doing
something like out of touch mark
ruffalo's there like with a you know a
poster board he's like sign me up like
i just find his presence so annoying and
i really haven't enjoyed him in any
filmography since just like heaven since
13 going on 30.
no just like heaven is an incredible
movie when reese witherspoon comes back
from the dead
yeah brian cranston your honor jeff
daniels the comey rule
okay um i forget but it was someone in
the beginning well we've only seen the
undoing but i like jeff daniels i'm
voting for him
i like jeff daniels too is he like the
chubby blond guy from the newsroom yeah
so that you know the newsroom i never
watched it
but the why are you laughing
why he why would you call me like the
chubby bunny girl he's chubby bunned
yeah by the way i don't like when people
like get offended like you know whatever
i'm really not even going there tonight
um so you know i've never seen the
newsroom but like the clip
that opens the show like tell us why
america is the greatest
the new york jets like that clip goes so
viral like it's
always coming up on my tic toc i've seen
it all over i've seen the clip a hundred
times like
i've seen the newsroom no i watched all
of the newsroom and i loved it so much
and i feel like i don't know what
happened to it
but i don't and i don't know if it's
like available to stream places but it's
such a good show and you know what's so
weird about jeff daniels in the newsroom
he's also dumb and dumber yeah
how do you do both that is called acting
right
that's why i think he should win you
know i actually i agree with you he
gives me like
grandfather vibes like i just want to
like like
you know sit on his lap and get presents
okay now it's time for our favorite
segment
what else has jeff daniels been
in yes we'll have to work on that but
okay
i m d b i am no it's easier google films
does a better
job but also google um like they
organize it at the top but again like
please use my data and know which movies
i've already seen
okay he was in dumb and dumber dumb and
number two the martian
terms of endearment steve jobs
he was in pleasantville that's such a
great movie who was he in pleasantville
i love
pleasantville i don't know who he was he
was in rv
which is one of your favorite movies
that is one of my favorites he was in
because of winn-dixie
such a stellar who is he an rv i
like it i think he was a competing
family's like rv like the father of the
competing family
oh by the way rv starring robin williams
cheryl from kirby enthusiasm and jojo
the singer
is literally the highest cinematic
achievement hollywood has ever put out
it is such an incredible movie they also
do a rendition at the end of the movie
of route 66 by rascal flatts
well it's not by rascal flatts but i
think roscott covers it in the movie
like
it's so good i'm gonna watch rv tonight
oh that's a good one
enjoy joj and then jojo comes in she's
like the moody teenager at the end
and she they're i think they're at some
wedding or something i don't know where
they're at and they go
into like all singing roots c6 66 and
then of course like jojo slays it you
know
yeah i didn't like rv as much as you did
i'll have to give it another chance oh
my god it's a movie
where i literally cackle like i i can't
breathe like
robin is so it's like my bad teacher
yeah yeah yeah
you didn't get it but also i haven't
seen it in so long that it might be like
a joy to re-watch because i don't
remember any of the jokes or the
opposite
oh yeah yeah yeah no but you should
re-watch it maybe i shouldn't so that i
can live like rent-free in my head is
the best movie of all time
okay best actor in a motion picture
comedy or musical andy samberg palm
springs sasha baron cohen borat
james cord in the prom lin-manuel
miranda hamilton dev patel personal
history of david copperfield
i don't really care like i'm happy for
all of you yeah i do think sacha baron
cohen in borat while i thought borat was
not good
he is excellent as the character yes
so there's something to be said about
that agreed okay best tv series drama
this is the major category and i think
that the nominees are lacking
the crown lovecraft country
the mandalorian ozark ratchet
what about queen's gambit what about
queen's gambit that's
really bizarre i know and i'm sure if i
went back to like the rest of my viewing
history like there's other shows that
have been snubbed and yeah i'm sure
brigitte
what about the engineering yeah like i
didn't i liked it
i liked it i liked it but i don't i i
wouldn't advocate for it to be no
queen's gambit like what the [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ] but um the crown is
so good
do we am i waiting for another crown
season or did i just finish one just
watched it oh that's
[ __ ] yeah best actress in a motion
picture comedy or musical
anya taylor joy emma didn't know she was
in something else oh
watching that roseman pike i care a lot
maria bakalova
borat kate hudson music michelle
pfeiffer french exit
it's just so crazy like how i literally
am a pop culture connoisseur and i say
this every time we go over nominations
for golden globes or oscars and i've
never heard of any of these movies i
know i just feel like we actually really
watched a lot of stuff this year so like
again i just feel like these choices
aren't my choices yeah i just feel like
growing up there was like four movies
that made it into every category and you
saw those four movies and like you were
a well-informed oscar viewer yeah
but i'm not i can't keep up with all
these like between all the streaming
services
there's so many movies that could be
best movie and it's just exhausting to
keep up
yeah soon we're gonna get into the
bigger categories but best actress in a
tv series drama
olivia coleman the crown jody comer
killing eve emma corrin the crown
oh two crowns laura lenny ozark sarah
paulson ratched
ozark is like a really big one zach was
watching it i heard ratchet was bad
yeah i didn't i never i didn't know like
anyone who watched it right and it's
like a ryan
murphy netflix show like and whenever he
does it you know he did hollywood he did
the politician like everyone dies for it
and it's like you see it everywhere
did not see one thing about ratchet
maybe it's good but i haven't heard
anything
yeah and then best actress in a motion
picture drama which are like the big
movies
frances mcdormand nomad land carrie
mulligan promising young woman
oh she's gonna win really i've been
meaning to watch that movie
i heard it's very triggering like if if
like there's a big trigger warning for
sexual assault on the movie but i heard
it's
incredible got it vanessa kirby pieces
of a woman
viola davis mourinho's black bottom
andre day the united states versus
billie holiday
oh by the way i've also been meaning to
see the billie holiday movie and i
didn't know that andre day
plays billie holiday it's a hulu right i
don't know what streaming service is on
um
i've been meaning to watch that movie
maybe we'll do that for toast movie of
the
oh that would be great the billy holiday
movie and then also best motion picture
drama which is like the big category
that'll probably reflect the oscar
contenders nomad land promising young
woman the father
mink the trial of the chicago seven okay
i'm gonna watch promising young woman
and the billie holiday movie that that's
that's what i'm going to do that's what
i'm going to contribute to the oscars
yeah but this is the golden globes yeah
but you know like this is just the
dress rehearsal yeah the golden globes
are just are they in person like what
are they i don't know what the setup is
going to be
one of my favorite things is when
celebrities post videos and themselves
finding out that they got nominated and
like you can tell it's really genuine i
just love watching like surprise videos
i just saw kelly cuocos because like
she's used to being on a sitcom like
she's not used to
working on golden globe worthy material
and she got nominated for
the flight attendant and her reaction
was quite joyous oh that's cute
it's like i also love watching military
homecomings i just love like surprises
yeah so beautiful so beautiful okay our
next story new couple alert
aaron rodgers and shailene woodley are
reportedly dating
and if you watch the morning toast we
discuss this in july and we
watch back what we said i said i was
quote here for it
and now that i'm seeing it you know
right in front of me i don't know that
i'm here for it
you know do not get any sort of
materials i'm not even close to like
building a ship do not get my building
materials out like i leave the toolbox
in the truck but it's like i won't be
burning down other people's ships
because i'm not
against it
honestly ever since aaron rodgers and
olivia munn broke up i just don't
believe in love
for aaron rodgers like i just think his
time is now she just like focused on his
career yeah because then like
he found danica and i was like you know
what like that's the one and that wasn't
the one either so i'm starting to feel
like maybe he's toxic like maybe it's
him
that's a really good point yeah the
green bay packers quarterback and
shailene woodley are dating according to
e news with the source telling the
outlet the pair have kept their romance
quote
private and low-key i will say though
like that's a good recipe for romance
they've been yes
they've been rumored together since july
it's not january we hadn't heard about
it and they're still going strong and
they were able to be low-key like
they might be in love agreed i just
don't know if aaron rodgers could really
get down with shaylene woodley's
lifestyle from what i know about it
she's very granola
she like you know makes her own soap and
she doesn't like you know but how do you
know
that he's not interested in making his
own soap i just have a feeling like
that's just not like what nfl guys do
you know maybe this is a stereotype
of me but i just feel like that's not
what they do make their own sophie me
yeah and i feel like if there's anyone
on the planet who i'm less
like incompatible with less have less in
common with it is one
shailene woodley like she made all this
money she's like i don't want it i'm
like okay give it to me
like oh material items i can have
anything i want i want nothing okay give
it to me
yeah can't relate to like her struggle
yeah so but opposites attract even
though we don't know anything
about his personality and maybe he does
make his own soap i know nothing about
him and to be honest like
after how he goes through women it's
like maybe it's not that interesting
like maybe they're leaving him because
he's boring
and all he talks about is football
football like we get it football and his
friends
yeah chill anyways that's the new couple
alert build your
ships at your leisure at your own risk
yeah
i'm done shipbuilding i'm done it's not
a fruitless
effort you know you spend all this time
like getting so many
ships for these people and then in a
matter of minutes it's just
we're back at the port we're by the port
back unloading
the ship yeah it's exhausting work
okay next story this one's for you our
fifth and final but i'm also gonna like
sneak in a little
fifth theory or in final year jeopardy
announces more guests hosts
and here they are we have anderson
cooper dr
oz savannah guthrie and dr sanjay gupta
okay four more guest hosts in the
rotation of maybe people just having fun
maybe people are auditioning
dr sanjay gupta and i were next to each
other in the bookstore and so there is a
special place in my heart for him
because he really legitimized my book
so i want him to get the job yeah or i
mean still i i think out of all of these
names maybe dr oz
resonates the most is someone who could
like be that person warm
welcoming vibe but still
i haven't found it i haven't heard it's
like it's i'll know when i see it
yeah and you know what even all those
people like i'm not even watching
jeopardy
all those people you named well yes they
are good hosts i don't know if they have
that factor
and you know who just came to mind i
mean we like saying here corey
no but yeah yes but you know who just
came to mind who
rachel ray kind of kelly clarkson
oh kelly clarkson it's like it's not the
next stop on her tour no but she would
be good at it
maybe in like the next few decades but
it's just like
that's not in her map what about oprah
i mean she's so rich she doesn't need
the money but like she could be that
energy
she could be oprah
just someone to think about yeah i would
love to see her guest host yeah
and then also i just wanted to add um
just some important
biz news is that jeff bezos yes
is no longer ceo of amazon he'll remain
chief of the board but he has stepped
down from his
ceo duties and it was your cuties
sweaty duties and it was revealed that
amazon web services ceo andy jassy would
take over as the main man
interesting i mean i can relate like if
i was so rich like why would i still be
working like going to work every day
like no sleep in jeff bezos and the
chairman
the chair of the board whatever he is
bored of the chair he can sleep in and i
feel that
he's worked really hard relax yeah he
said that running in
amazon at large is exhausting and
all-encompassing and he's got other
projects he wants to go all in on he'll
still have a hand at the wheel though
as executive chair of amazon's board
yeah i mean i'm wondering like is there
a scandal
like people don't step down so it's like
what's the scandal naked pics like what
did you do
well we already had those like we had
the text like that was that level of
scandal i want to get drunk with
you i want to read wake up and read the
newspaper
maybe he's just like stepping down
because he's embarrassed no because he
just wants to wake up and read the
newspaper
yeah and drink with her all night yeah
yeah no i just i
i'm curious there may be something but
you know what we said the same thing
about bob iger
but he stepped down remember because
there was still like two years on his
contract we were like oh there's a
scandal coming
there wasn't right but it's like you are
just tired you step down to avoid the
scandal so if they're stepping down it's
like we're not going to ever see the
scandal oh
probably oh i thought it was like
pre-emptive they do their jobs right
i thought it was preemptive like okay
the scandal's coming but at least i
won't be you know associated with disney
anymore you know
yeah maybe or maybe it's like this is
the
these are the terms you know what
disappoints me about bob iger
so we were never able to get in contact
with like one of his grandchildren you
know like when i feel like whenever we
say things on the toast i always get a
dm being like that's my brother
yeah i've not heard from a single bob
iger relative and that's upsetting that
is upsetting but keep dreaming
never stop keep dreaming reaching for
your goals um
should we do our tv recap segment yes
those were the stories and i feel as
though you needed to know them
for sure i feel very informed like i
feel like i just adjusted all that
information and
i'm feeling good feeling good good
enough
to cure the rdh but just in case just in
case
sneaking back i got to tell you guys
today's episode and the
tv recap segment is brought to you by
fab fit
fun so the spring box is coming where
you can choose from a wide variety of
products when you order
they offer 20 female founded brands in
the spring box this season
so we actually got the box it's so
fabulous like first of all when they say
full size items that come in the
the seasonal boxes like it is full size
items like in the box i got a full blown
duffel bag and it was so cute to have
like little daisies on it
from beauty and wellness to fashion and
lifestyle they really
curate very very good boxes very good
boxes for a reasonable price this is
like my fourth box now and i keep just
getting blown away by the
offerings there's so many things you
need and then also so many things you
did not know that you needed yes like
gel eye under eye patches yeah like yes
i need them would i ever like go out and
buy them for myself no
but now they're in the box gotta go i
got this wooden face brush that i had
like seen other people using
that i use now every morning and i just
feel like my lymphatic nodes are on
fleek your nodes are snatched yeah your
snatchy nodes notes
strategy nodes problems um it's just
like really a
uh a fabulous product and it's like a
little gift you know you forgot that
you're subscribing and then
all of a sudden this big beautiful box
comes with like fabulous scarves and
blankets and mugs and it's just
it's everything oh my god i got the most
amazing mugs from my box
they're huge they're huge they're like
these perfect tea mugs and as i've been
watching downton abbey i just i
literally feel like the dad was your
countess
and i think that's my favorite thing i
got from my box so far yeah the best
part is like you had all these fabulous
things and you don't have to leave your
house which is
really a a cornerstone of things that
are important to me yes
um if you want to use the coupon code
toast for 10 off your first box you can
do that at www.fabfitfun.com again
that's code toast
for ten dollars off your first box at
wwe
coupon code toast it is uh everything of
the sort
it really is okay real housewives of
dallas so you watch the last three
episodes so like you probably thought it
was like good
last two last two but like watching last
night's alone was so boring i guess
because of cobin maybe they're like have
limited
footage because like one whole episode
devoted to like brandy's birthday party
it's like kind of weird
yeah but then it was like there was the
other parts of the episode where
people's personal lives and just as
boring i was like not feeling that
either so i was like why didn't we get
more from randy's birthday but
there's only so much that they can do
and i actually thought they had a really
fun the day looked
very long it did but like i feel like
they were having a good time eventually
and i thought deandra did a great job of
planning
you know i'm in this place now where
like carrie is
so wrong and i'm really disappointed
because i love cameron but
time and time again i feel like when it
comes to fights she's always on the
wrong side of history
but i just love her so like i don't care
but like i'm always disagreeing with her
like carrie is wrong
but it's worth mentioning that like
carrie's obviously going through a lot
and she hasn't spoken up to the women
and i think that if she did
they would like give her a break because
she's acting so erratically and like
she's so nuts but she's going through
something so like if she had vocalized
it i think the women would have been
more sympathetic
towards her um and kind of given her a
pass for poor
poor behavior but nobody knows so she
just looks like she's just being insane
yeah i agree it was tough to watch and i
do feel like she is
just causing a lot of drama and i just
feel like she's in a bad head space like
with her kids like there's a lot going
on i think we learned last year like her
marriage isn't perfect i just think she
has a lot going on in her personal life
and that's why she drinks a lot and
that's why she's just like always
lashing out at people
and then also like she hasn't mentioned
it to anyone and then after
that she sit out and
i like yes so given that now they know
they should give them pass but it is
hard for like with
the women and i think deandra to just be
like oh okay well now i'm not mad
anymore
no it was you know so the wrong time
wrong place and i'm i feel like carrie
actually like felt really bad
like she almost didn't get permission
from her daughter to share it with the
women
yeah i felt like the way that that all
unraveled was just not
natural not and not what anyone would
have planned it just
it was kind of strange
yeah one of the things that i found
really interesting this episode was we
learned about jen who's like this friend
of housewife who like keeps hanging
around
and i think it's very clear that she was
intended to be filmed as a full-time
cast mate but something happened
maybe she was boring or whatever what i
read online was that there was like an
incident with her and her husband and
some sort of substance like they were
just
kind of messy and like yeah that's why
they
were too but then she's sitting talking
she doesn't drink she's sober like that
that was shocking to me
yeah so i think that's just a part of
her story yeah
i would have i was actually wondering
why because it sounds like it's super
dramatic and
like interesting yeah but bravo just
clearly drew the line and was like no
you're not gonna air this
also carrie referring to tiffany as
covet girl like is literally the most
out of touch
thing like of all time like in this day
and age like where we respect our
healthcare heroes and she's like out
here making a mockery of it yeah
and that was such a weird place that
that argument went to like
then coming down on tiffany for hanging
out with them even though she's exposed
because she's a doctor
i was just like what is this like what's
bubbling under the surface yeah no it
was so stupid it was so stupid
but i was glad that brandy put an end to
it because it was like getting really
off
yeah the wagon but it's clear that a lot
of these tensions remain
the one thing i will say about tiffany
as much as i am enjoying her it's very
clear that she has this baggage like
she's you know stressed about being a
mom and working full-time so like maybe
now wouldn't have been the best time to
join a reality show like
it just does feel like a little silly to
like watch her struggle with this when i
know she just took on a third job of
being a housewife which is
filming and reunions like it's a lot of
work yeah so i'm just kind of bored by
this whole like working mom guilt thing
which i know was like a real issue for a
lot of people but you just took on a
reality show so like
you should have figured that out before
you took on this new opportunity i
totally agree and we kind of opened the
episode with her
talking about it closed with her talking
about it it's a lot of her talking about
especially
like i always say for a new cast member
to get so into like your personal issues
when i don't even really know you yet
it's like i'm you have to earn that yeah
i'm not like fully interested in like
your
work life balance struggle couldn't
if that was just like her personal
storyline that would be f that is fine
but it's just she's getting the most
personal story time yeah
lying it's bizarre so i was just like by
the end i was really bored and it was
sad because she was so emotional and i'm
just like
i wasn't connecting to it at all yeah
i'm like so why did you take this third
job
yeah like the irony of her you know
crying in her room about being
overwhelmed by her two jobs
while doing this new third job like it
wasn't lost on me
also did you watch oh you did not watch
watch what happened to the first five
minutes it was so boring and like both
of their wi-fi were so blurry oh my god
what are you talking about yeah
literally i couldn't see anything
it was perfection terrible terrible
stephanie and tiffany were on watch what
happens live and i was nervous that it
was going to be awkward because like we
know that they had like a little bit of
yes drama because of stephanie talking
about the closet tour i thought it was
tiffany's first time ever on my travis
live i thought she did in them
she was sitting in her closet but no a
lot of things came up and
she pretty much one of the viewers asked
exactly what cameron said like how is it
not hypocritical for you
to push the chicken feet on her why you
didn't want the shots and
to call her a covered girl when she
called her cobra girl and she just like
completely um was like yeah no she was
like with the chicken feet thing i think
i was trying too hard i wanted to like
make a moment captain
scott like on tv eating a chicken foot
like how funny would that be and i i
just definitely tried like was trying to
write i'm like wow that's a really big
thing to admit like no that's very
mature so often we all try too hard and
like
and to not defend your own hypocrisy is
like the hardest thing to do trust me i
know yeah and so i just think
everybody i think andy was really
impressed by her i think that oh i'd
love that
yeah and i think that she's going to be
like amazing at reunions and i think
she's got it all going on well the thing
what we always say like the cornerstone
of a good housewife is being able
when it when it's the time
and you go down a very dark path when
you cannot ever once
own your [ __ ] and like you just deflect
everything onto someone else and like
nothing is ever your fault
that becomes like cyclical and really
boring to watch so that makes me happy
to to hear like
she saw herself on tv like doing two
conflicting things and she owned it like
it's not a big deal
it's so not a big deal now that she said
that like i'm never gonna think about it
again
right no but like it would always bother
me if she like never owned it yeah like
that's how i always felt about dorinda
like she never owned anything so i
couldn't move on to the next season
because i was still mad about what she
did in miami to bethany 100
also andy went on bethany's podcast and
i am 100 gonna listen to that
i saw a clip it sounded so good that's
exciting um
yeah can we do your toasters let's
please let's see what everyone's up to
dear toasters is our advice segment if
you ever want advice you can email us
deartoasters
gmail.com we will read your prompt
anonymously we will change names
you don't have to worry about any of
this this is a long one hi claudia and
jackie i love you both so much thank you
for always making my mornings great and
claudia so excited to read your book i'm
starting right after i send this
thanks here's the sitch at the last
super bowl in miami my boyfriend cheated
on me
after some time we've been able to
reconcile our relationship is better
than ever and i'm not worried about this
ever happening again
the real issue is all of this is his p
the real issue in all of this is his
parents
they don't know any of that stuff that
happened and i'm not exaggerating every
time i'm around them which is about once
a week they bring up him going to the
super bowl last year
that's weird that is weird they're huge
fans of the chiefs
and anytime they have a chance they will
say things like wasn't the super bowl
the best weekend of your life and it's
driving me insane
for christmas they got him a coffee mug
a beer mug in a mouse pad with a photo
of him at the [ __ ] super bowl
when we were at the house for christmas
his mother served me coffee in that mug
she also got one for herself and it took
everything inside of me not to chuck it
out a wall
we have completely moved past it so it's
really annoying that now in my own home
we live together
i'm constantly confronted by the hardest
thing we went through
in our relationship every time i do the
dishes i know his parents
i know if his parents knew about this
they would never bring it up again but i
know he really doesn't want them to know
is this part of forgiving him and moving
on i really do think i will be marrying
this guy and sometimes i think about how
my whole life i will never stop being
reminded of this incident
what should i do smash the mug right now
my plan is just to suffer in silence and
hope one day it'll stop
but i know if we do get married and this
continues one day i will crack and it'll
all be exposed
let me know what you guys would would do
because i am stuck from a triggered
toaster wow this is so hard no this is
just so not your problem to like
you didn't do anything wrong and now
it's constantly staring in the face and
i feel like part of your
boyfriend um being forgiven like what he
needs to do is like tell his parents
like listen
um he doesn't have to say i cheated on
you just say like
the super bowl is a source of contention
for us like i messed up that weekend
and please stop bringing it up at every
turn like i think he needs to say
something to them so just so that they
know that it's like a weird
spot in your relationship and assuming
that
once they know that they will stop
bringing all of these things up yeah and
honestly also like if you want if your
mother-in-law wants to serve him in the
mug in her house like that's fine but in
your house you do not need yes get rid
of the one in your house
but also you know what you could do like
you stand in the kitchen on the hard
on top of a hardwood floor and you hold
it and then you release
no literally like you could block it
kerplunk
the thing is though is that like i don't
know why we're like he [ __ ] up like
why we're protecting him so much like
tell you like the parents should know if
you're that close to them
but yes i it's not that we're protecting
him it's like who wants to dig this all
up again and now everyone knows and it's
like it just happened all over again and
she's finally gotten past it
it's it's for her as it is for him and i
think that they can just be like
politely nudged into being like
listen like that is just like a pit in
our relationship
please stop bringing it up if she is as
over the incident like as she says she
is then they should be able to get
through this like i don't think it'll
last forever
no and i think that the best way to go
about it is he needs to say something to
them
not just closing all the details but
like making it clear that he super bowl
is off-limits super bowl is just
a sore subject and you know what as more
super bowls pass
this will get less and less because
crazier things will happen at the next
super bowl you know and sally gets drunk
by the way i've been meaning to say we
need to put in our predictions
also you're saying that they're kansas
city chiefs fans so hopefully they
sign they win this super bowl hopefully
and maybe you guys should go to tampa
like tomorrow is this a sign i think i
should go to tampa hopefully chiefs win
new memories okay jackie who are we
giving it to
i'm going with the bucks
maybe we should do different ones that
way one of us is a winner okay because i
was gonna say the chiefs
okay great i just like to put my money
on the future not the past i understand
i just and i'm not gonna lie loved
kansas city when i went
fabulous place fabulous people i did
also go to tampa fabulous place fabulous
people but not as fabulous as kansas
city
i said what i know i don't know i could
see it going either way
no i think that the thing is there's
really a 50 50 shot i think one team is
going to win and one team will lose no i
think that's an actually really good
prediction
and i could see tampa winning and i
could see kansas city winning and i
could also see tampa losing and i
could hypothetically see kansas losing
i don't know i just i guess the city in
kansas city or is that one of those
missouri ones
oh asking the wrong person like i get
confused i think kansas city
is missouri and oklahoma city is
oklahoma there's one that's like not
in the city you know yeah okay yeah all
right next up
i'm still i just feel like i could see
myself watching the super bowl and being
like
how did i not bet on tom brady like duh
how many times does he have to tell me
right yeah yeah yeah before i believe
that he's going to do it but i could
also see it like being
the time like this no just like a
turning point where it's like
everything's in the rear view for tom
brady
yeah that doesn't feel you don't get to
the super bowl playoffs championship
just to be in the rear view
when it's in the rear view yeah no
you're right so he's still that tom
brady i'm going tom
all right next up how you doing claw
jacks theo and bruno sweets
darn good long time listener first time
caller i live in new york city and my
business man beau
and i rented an apartment at the beach
for the winter ooh that sounds so nice
it's a studio with no death so we both
work from the kitchen table
yesterday businessman beau requested i
not go behind his computer as he would
be on a video call
easy enough i then went to the bedroom
to change into workout clothes
without remembering that there was a
mirror behind him
i had just taken off my bra when i heard
him screaming much to my dismay it was
too late i had flashed the whole
group to make matters worse this was a
welcome to the team call for a new
analyst
welcome to the team here are my
girlfriends here are my girlfriend's
tits
he's so welcoming what now ladies his
group meets for outdoor
safe happy hours regularly and
significant others go
also he's a p-jump and i don't want to
break up with him do i bring it up and
laugh about it do i pretend it never
happened all while numbing in the back
of my mind that it did
help an itty-bitty titty toaster can't
relate oh well if it's city bitty
titties maybe he would think that there
was a man
stop no it's like like it's just less
stressful
here's the thing here's
the thing i just feel like i
we never really talked about the flip
side the flip side to having a
businessman bow oh you're right
that's a flip side which is that he's
constantly working
yeah it's exhausting you can't run
around naked like if you even if there
wasn't a mirror behind him like
if he's working like through the night
like the window behind him gets
reflective like
these are just the trials and
tribulations of having a businessman but
the thing is like you guys were so
conscious enough before this phone call
to be like let's not walk behind me
nobody really thought about the mirror
like how
things happen claude things really
really happened you would just [ __ ]
own it if that was me i'd be like yeah
those were my titties wanna pick
i would just i'm that girl five dollars
for a photo ten dollars for feet
i just feel like what i'm getting from
this story is like you guys have a good
relationship like
don't let this don't let this
sidetrack the good thing you have going
in terms of the happy hour just walk in
confident
walking confident like you're beautiful
stunning and smart
say walk in and say you're welcome and
just get a drink
a lot and then watch your titties again
yeah and this time intentionally
find a way to make a joke about it and
then like
but it's also a professional environment
it's like you can't you also don't want
like people
hr yeah yeah yeah that's a tough one
good luck
hey claudia i'm sure people have done
worse in these times you know oh yeah
we reported on that guy like six months
ago and started jerking off on jeffrey
two men but like
he lost his job and everything so it's
like that's not right we don't want that
that's not a good example
you know in these cover times like there
is a like a a
a line like between like accident i'm at
home like what do you expect from me
and unforgivable hello i'm a pervert
just your neighborhood sex offender
hey um all right third and final hey
claudia and jackie
how you doing damn good claude thank you
so much for your book i absolutely loved
it i laughed i cried i think i might
just have to read it again
thank you i swear that's written i
didn't make that up so my boyfriend and
i have been together for seven years and
living together for three
over quarantine i found it impossible to
sleep in the same bed as him
for the most part it is him allowing our
five-year-old chocolate lab to push him
over to my space
leaving me hanging off the bed when i
awaken to this in the middle of the
night and either move the dog over or
kick him off the bed to the dog bed
which is two feet away and very
comfortable my boyfriend gets upset
then there are nights when the dog is
sleeping on the dog bed and my boyfriend
will still maneuver his way into my bed
space and i'm once again hanging off the
side
when i nudge you sorry this is funny and
i'm seeing a lot of similarities to my
own life
when i nudge him awake and he once again
gets upset i've tried explaining to him
that he's never done this before and i
sleep like that
sorry i tried explaining to him that
he's never done this before and i sleep
like that
and don't move so it's completely on him
he says he just wants to be close to me
i know this is completely not true
because we were long distance for a year
and when we visited each other we never
had this issue he's a p-jump and i don't
want him to think that i don't like
sleeping with him but i feel like i'm in
a bad sleep i'm one bad sleep away from
drugging him with advil pm and red wine
we have a queen-size bed and we can't
fit a king up the spiral staircase in
our apartment
any advice love a burn toaster you know
what there is a special place in hell
for people who
get in your way of you in a good sleep
like i agree it's so
abhorrently offensive and this i take
personal
like i take personal events to this i've
been going through this
theo always sleeps in the middle of me
and ben's bed theo was small
we have a king bed it really works
totally fine but recently
theo has been deciding to lay
horizontally no
even if he lays horizontally he still
fits our bed is really big
he's been deciding to lay on ben's side
on the opposite side of the middle so
ben is now forced to move closer to me
and i wake up in the middle of the night
sometimes and ben is like breathing in
my ear
and i literally suck him i'm like get
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
he's like i don't care move him he's a
dog like
it's so disgusting i'm like i can feel
when someone's
on on me in my sleep and this is really
upsetting and you have to start laying
down some ground rules say like
listen i work eight hours a day i'm
[ __ ] tired put the dog in the bed
and get away from me yeah or stern
stern or it's time for separate bedrooms
yeah i just feel like it's just i'm
watching downton abbey and that's like
something that they used to do back in
the day they do it in the crown yeah
separate bedrooms and i just i see it
yeah no to be honest like you know when
people say like oh how's you know this
person's marriage
they're sleeping in separate bedrooms
you know like that sounds ideal i don't
think there's anything wrong with
sleeping in several bedrooms if you're
the type of person
who doesn't sleep well with others and
you like really value sleep like some
people can run on five hours of sleep
i check my health i get consistently
nine hours of sleep every night and i'm
still so tired
like sleep is important to me what about
you guys get like a really nice dog bed
for the dog to sleep on she said she has
one it's so nice
it's two feet away from the bed and it's
very comfortable so you're and then your
boyfriend can sleep on it
maybe you also just have to like put him
down yeah or your husband
or you need to move where you can have a
king bed like yeah that's a thing
you know i was um i forgot i was looking
at someone's instagram they were saying
how they just got a king bed for the
first time i forget who it was
oh it was julie wilson from cosmo
magazine
she said she said they've had a queen
bed their whole life and she's gonna get
a king bed now and i literally left a
comment i'm like this is going
to change your life like king beds if
you have the space
i cannot do you still sleep in a queen i
sleep in a queen bed
okay and that's insane i know and i have
the space for king and
i'm not gonna get one right now but like
and i ordered and you had a year ago
change your life i know
i know what am i doing what are you and
by the way your new bedroom is huge
huge but i can't get one right now
because three mattress companies reach
out
she needs one uh but it's like it's too
much change
no it's not jackie literally like in
me and ben's first we're literally
always on top of each other
like it's always it's always something
and me and ben's first apartment the
bedroom was really small and we still
shoved a king bed in there we didn't
have any room for nightstands we had one
dresser on a tv we had no room for
anything
it was the happiest i've ever been like
i would have it no other way even though
the room was perfectly sized
we could have had the cutest room if it
was a queen or a full bed
not gonna happen like i think that you
know a good sleep situation is
the root of a healthy marriage yeah but
we do have a good sleep situation and
bruno
does not sleep with us oh that's true
and if bruno slept with us it would be a
disaster but in a few years he will
start like i'm just like
in a few years i'll have a king i don't
know why you're like so against him you
just like you know
it's like it is sort of nice like we're
forced to like see each other in our
sleep
no and it's like hey i'm gonna vlog
sounds [ __ ] hard
that sounds disgusting like i don't want
to be at a certain point because like
when we sleep in a king bed in hotel
room beds like
we don't see each other like it's like
goodbye yeah
and so then when we come back to our
queen it's like oh hi how are you
no the thing is is that like with the
king
when we watch tv and like we before we
go to bed like we're in the middle ben's
on my side i'm on his side but then
a time comes when i'm like goodbye and
that's nice to have your own space
yeah okay i mean i know but
it doesn't i mean i sleep great yeah
yeah okay well good luck to you
like put rule with an iron fist sleep is
too important
yeah i don't know what we the suggestion
was but the suggestion was like
speak sternly to him he's getting upset
like what is he a two-year-old
you rule with an iron fist lady yeah
this is your home too
that's our show yeah that is our show
that you know you're right
that is our show no it's someone else's
show
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the first five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
already kept blocks all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning shows and leave a five-star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you have
an amazing amazing day
hump day let it let it take let it run
its course you know
and have a great [ __ ] day and we'll
see you tomorrow bye
you